all right what's your most proudest
moment I think when I did The Tonight
Show as a kid yeah
I read that um you showed me your diary
of when the day before you how old were
you two weeks before you did a Tonight
Show and then the entry right after you
did The Tonight Show and two weeks
before that you're like I hate this my
life's over I don't know what I'm doing
in stand up anymore and then you you
flip the page and it's it's your diary
your journal entry right after you did a
Tonight Show and you're like I think I
made it oh my God I can't believe it and
it was really sweet and you did how old
are you
almost 30 29. why'd you say when you're
a kid
I mean I thought you might go to your
eight and you went on with the animal
trainer what did he do on The Tonight
Show when he was eight years old I was
Short Round standing
for Indiana you know what's great about
that
'd be cool yeah
you know yeah
I stood in front of that too you know
but anyway yeah that was uh no when I
say kid because I feel like you know I
started at 23 as a kid as a comic
yeah yeah totally right so it's like
I've been doing comedy about seven years
and it was uh was it Leno Leno yeah yeah
yeah that's so crazy and I was working
the door at the time
I was like doing the background in The
Comedy Store and I was checking ideas
and I remember Bob Ross and Ross came up
to me when I was wearing my comedy store
t-shirt and they go we're here to talk
to you about the Tonight Show and I
remember going what do you mean yeah
yeah and I'm going no we think you can
do it we've been watching you at these
like open mics and stuff and I go
really and I remember from then on it
was like and I was so nervous really
because you know when you're at my level
at that time you don't they don't give
you a date you do the Fallout
right so if they have yeah
so were you doing that tight six yeah so
like I think it took months and months
where I was just waiting so you there's
you're just living with constant anxiety
almost like when is the day and then
when they got the call
you know I mean I was like ready you
know what I mean but um still very
nervous and I did it I remember feeling
I really I I even distinctly remember
what it looked like still today uh when
when I was on there looking at where I
knew where my manager was standing and
my brother I remember who was on the
couch it was Christina Ricci and Jay
Leno I remember like I remember like the
crowd and the cameras and it being like
you're on like it's something that you
would see in a TV show right like you
know and I was like oh no this is my
life right it looks like a studio
audience from you that you're watching
right on TV yeah it was really strange
like you yeah you're sitting behind the
scenes dissociative yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then I just remember like getting
called over the couch and all the little
moments you know what I mean in it and I
just remember and then going home and
laying in bed yeah and just with tears
in your eyes I love that and you're
going isn't he a great guy God I wish
somebody I can't I can't believe anyone
would ever break up with
[Laughter]
give TJ Miller a round of applause I
made a joke just then I know that we're
gonna close her we're gonna close out
I'm gonna tell you yeah I don't want to
talk about it you want to keep going and
I can't because I have something to do
with it yeah so you're uh you were how
old 29 yeah
uh and you killed it you knocked out of
the park yeah I think that that's that
in stand up is in some ways the Zenith
of making it rather than Madison Square
Garden or something else because there's
so much more pressure on you Bobby Lee
in this one moment this is that one shot
and that you knocked out of the park
yeah that is like that's a moment to
call your proudest moment yeah I don't
even really remember I think I did Conan
first yeah and I yeah it was kind of by
that time
so I'm very jealous because that The
Tonight Show that thing in stand-up
comedy history is the most important
thing you can do yeah it was and it was
uh for me it was Cloverfield
all right man
I'm just I'm saying I'm jealous of you
that's what I'm saying one out me with a
Hollywood movie what the [__] man I'm
being I'm being a great movie you're not
helping me and now I try to back pedal
and you're over there going great great
film much better than Bobby's Tonight
Show set well anyway give him a round of
applause TJ Miller thank you for having
me thank you
enjoy the peanut butter and enjoy the
hot sauce
[Music]
foreign